hi my name is Jacob Francis and I will
be your presentation on social analytics
using the mobile phone village
basically I was invited a few weeks ago
to just give it kind of like a rundown
give us some insight into what I learned
and then also just to kind of talk about
my project here with a couple of camp
students as well you might have seen us
walking around but I don't expect this
to go for the entire 20 minute period
but so if you guys have any questions
feel free to ask me but yeah so
essentially my project was a social
analytics project it's looking at well
specifically Twitter for the social
media network it's looking at trying to
connect emojis and actual tweets and
kind of created an association between
them to find the way that Twitter users
most commonly used in movies so I will
you be able to kind of see
visualizations of this later but
essentially the best way to just to
describe this is that emojis are a nice
way of depicting actual human emotion
whereas sometimes it's hard to decipher
what someone actually means in their -
in their text so it's kind of taking a
look at that sifting through a lot of
different a large query of tweets to
kind of make sense of you know what what
do you how do Twitter users actually use
this stuff so essentially using sir the
service Connect function or feature I
should say in them and the Wolfram
language made everything very easy so
this is just kind of it didn't actually
do anything on Elon Musk but this is
just kind of looking at a way that you
can pull very easily pull a number of
tweets so if I wanted to pull 10 tweets
from Elon Musk
I'm just being able to do that gives me
I have everything from the username URL
for the specific tweet all kinds of
stuff like that and then actually going
into the sentiment of the tweet I
actually just used Wolfram's built-in
classifier so didn't go into any I
didn't develop any kind of neuro neural
network or anything for myself I just
use the built-in one and kind of showing
how you can go through the different
texts and those tweets and be able to
determine what the sentiment of those
tweets were so basically the there was a
lot of and I already pulled a query this
is a queer that I've holed a long time
ago because there was over 24,000 tweets
that had to be sifted through basically
I have I set up all my functions
initially in the beginning so I might
refer back
these so I might be popping back in back
and forth but there was basically these
seven main functions that I had to refer
to for actually creating those
associations and then also creating the
data visualizations so for you know
actually I will just refer back to these
because without context they don't make
a whole lot of sense
but just know that they're there for
pulley for pulling information from
using service connect they're there for
creating the data visualizations and
then also for sorting data so that it
looks a little bit nicer basically so
first thing I had to do because Wolfram
doesn't by default unless you're using
the Apple color emoji font doesn't by
default actually represent the emojis
correctly I just rasterized them because
I didn't want to change the entire font
of my entire notebook so by doing that
then you get just a list of basically
small images so that they're easy to use
throughout the rest of the project and
this was took actually a longer time
that you might expect just because I it
took it took me four honestly we can
have to actually figure out how to use
our visual ecv emojis within here
it was help with Rick who is my mentor
at the camp to actually able to figure
out how to use emojis there was a lot of
hiccups with them now kind of this is
like an example right here this gets
sentiment of my tweets which tweets
again is that pre-cooled query it's it's
just a very big list essentially of
tweets that I won't that I'm hiding just
because it's really ugly
but that I'm using the get sentiment
function basically what it's doing is
just a list of lists of different tweets
and then they all map with different
emojis so what this is doing is it's
iterating through and just applying that
classifier function to each of those
tweets to determine whether they are
positive negative or neutral and then
also getting rid of any that are
indeterminate to work out if kind of get
rid of any outliers so then by doing
this it takes actually surprisingly
surprisingly quick how fast it's able to
do it considering okay so there's about
24,000 tweets it has to go through but
that was what I did essentially just to
kind of first
take all the tweets and then condense
them down into a format that was that
was understandable and then taking that
and then just getting a positive
negative neutral for all of those after
that though this is just an example of
this is actually this is kind of an
example of if I can make this a little
bigger or this one a little bigger kind
of looking at the actual individual
distribution of sentiments for a given
emoji so I think that it's important to
kind of see you know is it used in a
mostly negative and mostly positive
50/50 is it used 5050 positive and
negative most of the time is it use any
mostly positive I'm wait a lot of the
time so you can kind of look at some of
the ways that users are using these
different emoticons on Twitter in more
depth but then following that I write
here basically to actually take a look
at like numerical values for this
because you know you can look at
positive negative and neutral all day
and it won't make really make any sense
what I did I mean I just formulate this
myself it's not really anything that
complicated basically I just gave
everything a score so if it's positive
it was one it was negative is negative
one if it was neutral to zero so I just
created it basically a keys and values
to do that and right here essentially
all I'm doing is iterating through all
that raw data creating those maps
between the actual physical words and
then their numerical values and then
finding a total score so to speak so you
know cuz if an emoji is mostly using a
positive context is going to have more
weights in the positive one Direction
more than the negative one and so being
able to do that and this is just a list
essentially which again still correlates
with a another list of the actual their
corresponding emojis but creates a list
that is actually gives you a numerical
representation of its sentiment or it's
in that sentiment score and so then this
was just kind of curious this was this
was certainly that sparked my interest
when high went through and actually
found the most negative emoji the most
negative emoji is actually the
the thinking emoji so it's like it's
it's really weird I don't know why it's
that it's it's doing a little it's kind
of small I know the rasterization czar
quite small but it's doing a little like
thinking it's a thinking emoji and now
my a my my just because I mean I use
Twitter so my hypothesis would be that
most people use it in a in a sarcastic
sense a lot of time so when you think of
like the way that the classifier
function is looking at it it's looking
at just in terms of what it's literally
saying and then you get that aspect of
actual human emotion with the emoji so
you can kind of determine well maybe
because this isn't the thinking emoji as
shown here doesn't seem to have just by
looking at it ain't necessarily a
negative or positive sentiment to it so
kind of looking at the weird quirks
about how people use different emojis on
Twitter just thought that was kind of
interesting now in addition to this the
I got you got like a distribution of all
the different emojis now this is very
hard to see just because they're what I
did had like 200 or not 200 hundred
something emojis not all of them there
I'm way more than that but that would
have been a lot of a lot of tweets to
pull but basically I had to first sort
through this is referring back to
another function that I had before I
could go back to it real quick the sort
emojis function right here all this is
really doing it it's just sorting the
emojis based on the ordering of that
list that I had from before based on
their net sentiment scores so first it's
taking those that list of just numerical
values for each emoji it's sorting those
and then it's flipping it's also sorting
that list of emojis on based on the same
ordering of the other lists that I had
that way you can get a you you can sort
both both the emojis list and the list
of actual scores so that they are
aligned with each other so basically by
running this I mean it's gonna give me
the same output but that just then
allows me to go and create a bar chart
that isn't just a bunch it's not just
going up and down all over the place you
get kind of a progress a continual
progression from the most negative to
most positive and like I said these are
very hard and small small and hard to
see but the most positive one is
actually it's an emoji with stars in its
eyes and actually not not really ironic
but that's actually the one that was
right here which is right next to the
most negative one but that one was I
guess in that night by no surprise
positive but the second most positive
one is actually in angry emoji which is
this guy right here so again looking at
potentially how these are used in a
sarcastic sense or sense that I guess
doesn't make do most people who don't
use these forms of social media now if
you want to look at kind of more of a
cellular or a table I also just set up a
function for creating a data set because
if you want to take a look at well you
know a pie chart is great for
visualization and a bar charts great for
like looking at all the data in a very
you know coherent way or a way that just
represents all the data in one easy easy
to see fashion but a data set I think
just for in terms of looking at
numerical values it's great because you
are able to just take a look at you know
just the numbers again but he's more
easily represented than something like a
list and that just kind of gives you
well this is what people this is how
people are using them and also kind of
showing you the balance between the two
like for example here this emotion she
is pretty balanced as you can see
between positive and negative and then
you have other words other ones that are
skewed just another way to look at the
data as well but that was really the
essence of my project this summer I
planned on expanding this a little bit I
was actually going to be looking at not
so much emojis but actually the
progression I should say of sentiment in
a specific user so kind of as I did on
the first slide when I was looking at
Elon Musk's tweets being able to there's
actually a date associated with that so
then using just a date a date a date
list plot or a date plot not sure which
one I would want to use exactly but that
being able to pull because you can pull
up to 5,000 or I believe it's up to
5,000 tweets in one single query being
able to do that and then group by date
and then
actual like net sentiment over time to
see well I was just curious because
especially with all the fire that Elon
Musk has been recently with the SEC and
all that stuff
being able to see well maybe he's
becoming more irritable on Twitter
please but that was something that
unfortunately I wasn't able to do before
this conference but yeah that was pretty
much the essence of my summer project I
can do a lot more detail than we had we
had about two minutes to give a
presentation at the actual camp yeah I
suppose that's really about all for my
entire project though is there any
questions or anything like that
[Applause]